الاخت حسنيه
حسنيه
الشولي
الحاجه ام عصام اخت علاء ابو حسين ووالده
عصام وهشام
توفيت البارحه نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان
يغفر لها وان يرحمها وان يتوب عليها نساله
سبحانه وتعالى ان يكتبها في عليين
وان يغسلها من
ذنوبها بالماء والثلج والبرد وان يباعد
بينها وبين خطاياها كما باعد
بين المشرق والمغرب ونساله سبحانه وتعالى
ان يفسح لها في
قبرها وان يمد لها فيه مد البصر نساله
سبحانه وتعالى ان يلحقها
بالمهديين
والشهداء والصالحين
والصديقين اللهم امين
[Arabic recitation]
نفع الله بها
كثيرا
تصلح بين الاواج تعلم
[Arabic recitation]
غفر الله له
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
[Silence]
مستحبات
وضو
need
to understandates
understand what contr
and
the here ment
invidators
‏things
that willate
now here we are again with very
important point what is this point
is this
all that all of the scholars have ever
said with respect to what invalidates of
course not
many things have been mentioned
however
‏con usarleidence
and
not everyle
everyle sch is equ to everything else
that every other ‏say
I think this is something that is given
but it war
not everything that every scholar says
is equal and equivalent to every other
thing that every other scholar says.
Scholars are not all the same. They are
not all of the same level.
[Silence]
يقول ابو السعود
في مراقيه وليس كل قول قيل معتبرا
الا قول له حظ من النظر
الا قولا له حظ من النظر
‏iscept
those opinions which haveableid
so
we are
fromران
يقول المؤلف ما خرج من السبيلين هذا اول
شيء وهذا ما اتفق عليه العلماء
ما خرج من السبيلين لكن شو رايكم لو حكيت
لكم
حتى هذا ليس مجمعا عليه هل الاجماع شرط في
قبول الدليل
هل الاجماع شرط في قبول القول
ايش الجواب يا اخوان
الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول قولا
واجمعت الامه على هذا القول هل زاد قوله
قيمه اجماعهم
[Arabic recitation]
من قوله شيئا لا اذا الاجماع
تابع للنصوص وليس العكس
الاجماع تابع للنصوص وليس العكس
[Silence]
private
anything
‏that
is
I could mention to you opinions that
have that wouldutely blow your mind
would grow yourir back and would make
your fall out
right why is
‏have
life from all different and have said
many things
as of ourion isle
one of them had their their statements
preserved. That's amazing. ‏Not
everything that has been said is
necessarily correct.
And so
the first two is or the first one that
the counts as one is anything that comes
out of the front or back.
يقول من بول او غائط او ريح لقول الله
تعالى او جاء احدك احد منكم من الغائط وهو
كنايه عن قضاء الحاجه ولقول النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم لا يقبل الله صلاه احدكم
اذا احدث حتى يتوضا
فقال رجل من حضرموت ما الحدث يا ابا هريره
قال فساء او ضراط
الفساء
ما خرج من الريح
وهو الذي ليس له صوت والضراط ما كان له
صوت
وهذا الحديث متفق عليه في الصحيحين
يقول المؤلف كما ينقضه خروج المذي والودي
عن ابن عباس رضي الله عنهما قال المني
والودي والمذي اما المني فهو الذي منه
الغسل واما الودي والمذي فقال اغسل ذكرك
او مذاكيرك وتوضا وضوءك للصلاه والحديث
سبق تخريجه وبيانه والله اعلم صلى الله
وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين والحمد لله رب العالمين جزاكم
مش عار
الله
ماسام طليهاك
[Arabic recitation]
شوف ممكن الصلاه حتى تكسب ان شاء الله
يعني الظهر العصر ان شاء الله حتى نبلغ
الله
يتقبل
الصالحات
ام للجميع الجميع للجميع
الله